con las aves
cuando queremos que alguien confíe en
nosotros
no sabrá su corazón no sabrá su casa le
decimos
te doy mi palabra como si le diéramos la
cosa más importante que tenemos cuando
estamos dentro del cuerpo de nuestras
madres
los órganos empiezan a formarse según
las necesidades de cada momento
primero el corazón es el que la tiene
en el anuncio previo pues el hígado
los riñones al final los pulmones para
respirar y después hay un órgano externo
un órgano que nos ponen que es el nombre
el nombre es el órgano que nos va
invisible que nos va a caracterizar y
vosotros me veis aquí decís mira
benjamín
además cuando nacemos no solamente el
nombre nos caracteriza a nosotros sino
que el nombre afecta a toda la gente que
está a nuestro alrededor
fijaros que había una señora que era
madre y ahora es también abuela
y había un señor que era
hermano y ahora es el tío
hay primos un hijo único que ahora
también es el hermano
sobrinas
como tiene que haber todo en el mundo
hay cuñados también
decía
el segundo oponente nicolás que servía
para unas cosas más que para otras yo
cuando yo también quería ser científico
pero era demasiado inteligente para eso
y tuve que ser poeta
porque creo que la poesía es la que
finalmente termina cambiando realmente
el sentido auténtico de las cosas de
volviéndose de como esas células madre
de las que hablaba álvaro en su primera
intervención curan cosas repara cosas y
añade cosas creo que y lo digo con toda
sinceridad que para mí el la distancia
más corta entre dos puntos es la que une
a quien escribe un poema y a quienes lo
leen porque los buenos poemas son
espejos no son autorretratos los buenos
poemas no cuentan la historia del que
los ha escrito o no sólo la historia de
que los haya escrito sino que cuentan
también la historia de quienes los leen
y añaden cosas le devuelven algunas
cosas su sentido esas cosas que perdemos
por desgracia con la edad con los años
con todas esas pérdidas a las que hacía
referencia a lo má también
perdemos ilusiones perdemos emociones
perdemos el sentido de la confianza en
mucha gente nos hacemos más cautelosos
y la poesía limpia todo eso porque la
poesía lo explica todo con tres o cuatro
palabras y añade cosas el buen poema
intenta siempre encontrar el sentido
memorable de las cosas para que las
cosas no vuelvan a ser nunca exactamente
igual después de leer a neruda
hace un momento
a paul valéry
alejandra pizarnik porque porque es
verdad que menuda escribe un libro de
odas elementales
en las que los poemas no tratan del
atardecer ni del océano ni de la patria
ni de la persona amada
tardà tratan hay una oda a la cebolla
hay una oda a las tijeras como se ha
mencionado hay una oda a los calcetines
un nuevo tema literario los calcetines
un temazo
claro los que neruda los calcetines se
les llama liebres suaves
menuda le llama la cebolla redonda rosa
de agua
ya no saben igual las ensaladas a que no
paul valéry define el ruido del mar
estamos aquí al lado del cantábrico a
que suena al mar es un sonido
bonito
inquietante y llega por valeri escribe
el cementerio marino uno de los poemas
más conocidos del siglo 20 y dice ese
tumulto análogo el silencio
como puede ser el tumulto y el siglo del
frío dos cosas análogas eso consigue la
poesía que dos palabras que nunca habían
soñado siquiera con estar juntas al
unirse causar una explosión como las que
causan estos científicos que nos han
hablado en sus laboratorios
cuando juntan dos líquidos que tienen
que implosionaron tienen que producir
nitrógeno tienen que hacer cualquiera de
estas reacciones con las palabras pasa
exactamente lo mismo y nosotros
necesitamos palabras porque las palabras
son las que nos diferencian del resto de
los bichos no solamente andar sobre dos
pies
decimos que descendemos del mono es
increíble que algunos desciendan de tan
alto verdad
pero lo que no significa
lo que nos dice
la capacidad de comunicarnos de
emocionarnos de decir a una persona no
solamente de quererla sino decírselo
te quiero
porque no hay pareja más triste que esas
en las que uno de los dos lo más
romántico que ha dicho en la vida es y
yo a ti hombre por favor esfuérzate un
poquito cómo vas a reducirlo todo y yo a
ti no
la poesía nos da las palabras que
necesitamos para negar esa tozuda
realidad que nos quieren imponer desde
los poderes económicos neoliberales y
demás de que todo se resuelve con un
número todo es número todo es una cifra
todo es un tanto por ciento
y entonces dices bueno este mes hay
50.000 parados más
pero en realidad son menos porque en el
mismo trimestre de hace cinco años del
pero yo pienso en esos 50.000
cuando queremos defender a un terreno
directamente pedestre el de la
actualidad que importante son las
palabras verdad
a que no es lo mismo rebelión que
sedición
no porque el código penal dice que hay
una diferencia de nuestros años de
condena ante una cosa y la otra incluso
las mismas palabras cambiadas de orden a
que no es lo mismo presos políticos que
políticos presos dejar lo importante que
son las palabras simplemente las mismas
en la de una frase cambiada de lugar lo
cambia todo la poesía es la madre de
todas las palabras la madre de las
grandes palabras lo que se elige dentro
de un poema se recuerda de una manera
como no se recuerda nada más por eso los
anuncios de los que nos acordamos
siempre son aquellos que estaban en
verso rafael alberti uno de los grandes
poetas del siglo 20 yo tuve la suerte de
ser su alumno siempre decía un chico que
cosa rara esta verdad uno que ha sido
íntimo amigo de picasso de lorca de
neruda
me moriré acordándose de un anuncio que
escuchaba cuando era niño no radio mi
madre que decía qué maravilla la lana
mar lloret no sea polilla era rafael
alberti no era rafael alberti
las palabras nos caracterizan las
palabras nos definen y las palabras de
un poema son las mejores y en el mejor
orden es muy fácil de explicar podemos
un uno de los poemas más conocidos
y justamente de la literatura española
el retrato de antonio machado
y qué dice el retratado ante los machado
dice la cosa muy sencilla muy fácil todo
el mundo lo entiende mi infancia son
recuerdos de un patio de sevilla y un
huerto claro donde madura el limonero
es ancha
que era de sevilla
y tenía un huerto con un limonero
bueno pues recurramos a un elemento muy
característico de nuestra de nuestro
maravilloso idioma castellano que es el
el sinónimo no se supone que los
sinónimos valen para todo yo lo mismo
puedo ser delgado o alto que esbelto no
sitúa el poema de machado le cambia su
infancia por niñez
y le cambias patio por jardín
y le cambias recuerdos por memorias
no porque machado cogió las mejores
palabras y las puso en el mismo orden y
eso es lo que hace que se ponga sea
inolvidable y que cuando uno lo lee una
vez en su vida normalmente no lo vuelva
a olvidar nunca más
la poesía nos defiende la poesía es un
arma
no sé si cargada de futuro como decía
gabriel celaya pero si es un arma que
nos defiende de esa globalidad que nos
han vendido
y hace pensar que todo tiene que ser
igual todo el tiempo en todas partes y
para todo el mundo y yo creo que no yo
creo yo creo que la igualdad consiste en
que todos podamos ser diferentes también
cada uno a su manera decía paloma antes
se hablaba del famoso miedo al folio en
blanco el folio en blanco ese miedo se
soluciona llenándolo de palabras pero es
que los lectores también estáis en
blanco cada vez que escribo un poema
el que lo recibe es una mujer o es un
hombre en blanco para mí un paquete sin
abrir al que le tengo que rasgar el
envoltorio intentar meterme dentro de él
y convencerle de que las cosas son como
yo digo que son y si yo digo que unas
tijeras son dos ríos amarrados y un
pájaro que vuelvan las peluquerías no os
van a volver a aportar el pelo igual
eso es lo que va a pasar cuando leáis
ese verso las palabras evitan dan
argumentos dan ideas no ocurrencias como
tienen algunos de algunos sino ideas
ideas profundas ideas que nos expliquen
lo que somos quiénes somos qué derechos
tenemos que no somos todos iguales que
no somos todos iguales y que no todo se
puede explicar con un número y con una
cifra que esa idea de qué
lo que vale para una persona vale para
todas las demás esa idea de que se
pueden imponer carácter por reglas que
no hay adn que explique en este mundo
están equivocadas y la poesía te explica
exactamente eso te explica cómo combatir
esas imprudencias de un mundo en el que
parece que no tenemos derecho a pensar
que no tenemos derecho a ser distintos
que no tenemos derecho a arriesgarnos
que no tenemos derecho incluso a opinar
o que no nos podemos salir de los
carriles que nos han puesto no ahí llega
federico garcía lorca que no era
especialmente un político y dice se va a
nueva york- de fin los defectos del
capitalismo que también los tiene
y escribe un poema en el que dice cosas
como
de la esfinge a la caja de caudales hay
un indefenso que atraviesa el corazón de
todos los niños pobres y yo creo que ese
verso tenía que estar en todas las
escuelas escrito en los encerados porque
explican muchas cosas sobre cómo
a veces hemos creado sociedades que nos
atenazan sociedades que nos coartan
sociedades que nos ponen todo el rato
bayas y es verdad lo que decía paloma en
su intervención una o uno tiene que
seguir su propio camino tiene que elegir
las vallas que quiere saltar e incluso
las vallas en las que quiere tropezar y
tiene que elegir el tipo de vida que
quiere yo estoy convencido de que si si
fuera mentira es lo que ha contado ella
que el 85% de las personas
de la nada su trabajo es un horror es
como ir al infierno todos los días yo
creo que si la gente fuera feliz en
aquellos gases no habría ni guerras
probablemente
estoy seguro no pasaría nada de eso de
manera que la poesía yo la entiendo
desde luego como un
y acto artístico también artesanal no es
lo mismo el arte lo puede tener uno de
fábrica la artesanía se lo tiene que
fabricar con
con las manos y trabajando muy duro cada
una de las palabras de cada uno de los
poemas le pregunta a hemingway un día
su mujer qué tal tu día de trabajo dice
fantástico ha sido fantástico he estado
por la mañana que tengo una coma que nos
molestaba un mentor un montón y antes de
cenar justo la volvía a poner
un día de trabajo extraordinario porque
si tenía que estar ahí y tuvo que
quitarla para darse cuenta del valor que
tenía que tenía la coma bueno las cosas
que dice un poeta las puede decir en las
puede decir en prosa como estoy
intentando hacer esta tarde y las puede
decir en verso o en prosa
les recomiendo siempre que hablo con
alguna algún joven poeta de estos
fantásticos es padre de una generación
de poetas maravillosa gente que se
atreve a decir cosas nuevas con otro
lenguaje con otra expresión y que están
menos coartados a lo mejor por algunos
56 que teníamos la gente de mi edad hace
unos años y que fuimos librándonos de
ellos poco a poco y es decir ser
valientes nombrando todo no tengáis
miedo ser positivos reclamar también la
alegría no reclamase solo la tristeza la
melancolía el drama que parecen más
propios de la poesía parece que en la
canción pasa un poco lo mismo también y
yo luego muchas veces en una canción con
lo que te quedas es con lo divertido con
lo simpático con la capacidad para
celebrar la felicidad para celebrar el
amor para celebrar tu país si es que te
gusta con las bromas también porque no
se puede gastar una broma en un poema o
en una canción mi amigo sabina tiene 40
mil geniales no mi mujer a mi primera
mujer era una arpía pero macho el punto
del gazpacho si lo tenía
es una genialidad equivalente a me
gustas cuando callas porque estás como
ausente hay que ser todo un poeta para
escribir eso lo digo en serio bueno
tengo un poema en uno de mis libros que
se llama cuestión de principios y que
quiere explicar en verso esto que he
intentado explicaros en prosa que es que
en la vida no hay nada que valga tanto
como aquello que nos hace sonreír
emocionarnos ser felices celebrar bailar
no os dais cuenta cuando cuando la gente
de cualquier edad está en la playa son
niños
niños de 4 años o de 40 o de 69 son
niños se salpican se empujan se gastan
bromas jugar no perdamos nunca la
capacidad del juego y cuando escribimos
tampoco por cierto y cuando leemos
tampoco esto se llama cuestión de
principios y digamos que sería lo mismo
sólo que más breve no la poesía no está
solo como decía leonard cohen en esos
libros donde los renglones no llegan al
final de la página la poesía también es
una forma de leer es una forma de vivir
es una forma de querer es una forma de
comportarse es una forma de ser de
gentes todo eso es la poesía que nos
libra de las prosas horrorosas de este
mundo que a veces nos aplasta a base de
números y números
un poema que diga también lo que no dice
un poema que escuche a quien lo lee
un poema que nunca olvidarán las
palabras con las que lo haya escrito
un poema que sabe lo que piensas un
poema que sea incorregible que se lo
note a todos los que lo han comprendido
que no sueñe que lo haga otro que no sea
yo
un poema que sea raro que no existiese
un poema que ladre a los desconocidos un
poema que diga que el que cierra los
ojos es cómplice del crimen que no ha
querido ver
un poema que ponga en peligro la poesía
un poema que mires como los pasajeros
consultan sus relojes en la estación de
tren
un poema que sea capaz de repetir
justicia
y corazón libertad
y alegría muy buenas noches a todas
[Aplausos]